I've been getting a bunch of hate
comments and I'd be lying if I said it
doesn't hurt me but sometimes enough is
enough people dare online question
saying oh he doesn't really play video
games anymore oh he's not really a gamer
anymore oh excuse me you think I'm not a
gamer pity pie the biggest gaming
channel on YouTube oh I'm not a gamer
I'm such a gamer then why do I have a G
fuel sponsorship
then why do I have this gaming chair
that can in fact do a lot of things why
do I have these gaming headphones why do
I have these gamer muscles if I wasn't a
gamer always because I don't dress like
a gamer oh I'll have you know I have
quite the taste for a gamer fashion okay
here's some of my favourite gaming
outfits and maybe you can learn a thing
or two if you pay attention no mom I
can't pause fortnight
that's a shirt that says I like
videogames and also I like fortnight and
also mom I can't pause in fortnight you
what is this measly youtuber merge
migraine is 90% gaming tactics and 10%
random stuff there are more than two
genders I have not seen a more gaming
more than t-shirt in my life I don't
leave the house unless I tell people
about my core message eat sleep
fortnight rip heat eat sleep fortnight
repeat oh I'm sorry I wasn't listening I
was thinking about gamer tactics oh if
you were reading this I'll have you know
I was forced to put my controller down
and endured society society what even
insist
xiety huh has anyone ever thought of
that I really really would recommend
these ones I especially like how the
print just ends in the middle of the
shirt these full covered shirts they're
very epic especially the one with the
hem typefaces some people would go for
the head typefaces I'm more of a
fortnight all over kind of guy yeah I'm
a gamer good at making extremely hot
girls now this is what gaming is all
about some say there's females other
saves they're males I see there's only
one gender video games ruin my life
lucky I have two more cuz I'm a gamer
for the best thing about a gamer is that
I don't age just levels up to next level
born to play fortnight forced to go to
school
I'll take time I'm a gamer not because I
don't have life but because I choose to
have many way someone Photoshop that I'm
a gamer not because I don't have life
but because I hate it's this kind of
toxic gaming attitude that makes me sad
to be a gamer if I can't identify my
entire existence through a hobby that
literally everyone takes part in then
Who am I Who am I supposed to be hey
snowflakes I shouldn't wear the shirt
who buys these shirts I know I do
because I'm a gamer gamers don't die
they respawn
do not disturb gaming mode well this one
isn't too bad
hey Brad you can wear this one what the
hell who sells this this is not gamer
approved I do not approve of this I am a
gamer not because I don't have life but
because I hate what is stay stop stop
this horrible messaging warning I have
leg mine Ninja has leg MA oh I got it I
got it yeah born to be a gamer forced to
go to school
I'm a born ass gamer the reflexes I can
react in 0.1 millisecond you know what
they told me my entire life
oh well you play video games it's never
gonna get you it's never gonna get
you money
oh what I'm slamming out both bro I'm
slamming out both gamer gifts so much
heat just why I'm all about the gamer
love why did I buy that this is not even
game early if you're a gamer say it with
me loud and clear
eat sleep gamer repeat eat sleep game
repeat eat sleep game repeat I play for
like 6 hours and billion years I can't
read that upside down but I'm sure it's
gaming related I don't think I've ever
felt this powerful who needs a
girlfriend when I can make Hatsune Miku
touch my oculus rift yes that one please
yes I am a gay furry if you ask nicely
I pass my game to be here literally I
have minecraft paws right now so I'm
going to say my outfit is a bit over the
top it's called a coordinated baby it
doesn't get better than this I'd
literally can't sweat through my armpits
because nothing can leave my body
remember when he wasn't cool to play
video games
and you had to be secret about it I went
outside once the graphics are not that
great have you seen the graphics in the
new League of Legends patch what the
hell what can i buy that I actually want
that unless my t-shirt says hashtag
gamer and takes up half the book then
I'm not that interesting yes I like
video games no I'd want to date you
we are rare attractive men that likes
video games we are rare women wants to
take over us they want to abuse us for
our skills and gaming's but we're
smarter than that
dude dude dude dude I'm logged out for
this that's mean basically any scenario
my mom's dying where it's her funeral
she's dying at her feet girl dude
I logged out for this mom I hope I'm
making myself clear here I'm not playing
around this is not some kind of video
game I mean it is but this is not some
sort of game whenever I can't breathe no
I'm a gamer because I never stopped
giving up I never don't give up my DNA
dad does anyone want to challenge me any
wonder he won rust
anytime of
it does see yes come the striking 1.6
I'll go one be fine if I have to if
there was one game or merch to rule them
all instinct ate a million club merch
available right now on represent dot-com
flash pewdiepie now they suspect that
Isis type merch you see this if this
doesn't make you convince you to finally
buy that PewDiePie merch they even think
thinking about and I guess nothing's
gonna come inside Slager of a girl
gaming I guess girl gamers can have
swagger too what can I say I've learned
some people have been telling me like
dude girls can be gamers too and I'm
like no no man that ain't it that's
impossible but I've been educating
myself I want to be clear here don't
piss me up I'm close to leveling up and
securing the existence of our people and
if what that goddamnit
no gamers make better lovers we press
the right buttons never happens with
someone in pressed buttons you ever done
that you haven't because you're a gamer
that's right we don't have now pound it
pound it if you're a gamer daughter
goddammit I say with me I'm okay guys
this is my coming out video I know now
that I have no reason to be afraid I
have no reason to be ashamed of Who I am
I have no reason to pretend that I'm not
I'm proud my name is Felix Kjellberg
coach albergue and I am proud to say I'm
a gamer I am proud to say enter the code
PewDiePie to get your gene for your game
our free fuel 30% off for those epic
moments in video games I had some of my
best times in my life while drinking G
fuel I lost my virginity while drinking
G fuel I got my first victory reality
while drinking G fuel you don't
understand the power of a gamer how long
can I drag out this joke I
no but it's going on way to hook